oh look
after brady's done with the nfl he won't
be staying home with gisele
yeah fox didn't wait to start paying the
quarterback that's still playing tom
brady has signed a massive broadcasting
deal with fox sports to analyze nfl
games after his retirement the 10-year
contract is reportedly worth 375
million dollars
now he can finally afford to get his
ugly face fixed
what a homely guy
he's no madison cothorn
let's be honest
brady's
anyway brady who is widely considered
the greatest quarterback of all time
although he's no trent dilfer
[Laughter]
will now also become
trent tilfer the highest paid nfl
broadcaster of all time but good for us
i say hiring tom might be the best
decision someone at fox has made since
hiring yours truly
thank you thank you oh stop
stop we're going to edit it out anyway
which raises the question can two titans
coexist at the same company
one of us is a legendary athletic
specimen adored by millions and the
other is tom brady
saw that one coming didn't you yes i did
yes so let's look at the facts shall we
it's the tale of the tape greg gutfeld
versus tom brady who's the most
successful graduate of sarah high school
in san mateo california let's look at
the numbers gutvelt five new york times
best sellers brady one duck belt three
wildly successful tv shows brady none
gut felt no super bowl lawsuits brady
three super bowl losses gut belt stands
six foot five is muscular and handsome
brady stands only six foot four is
doughy and ugly gut felt played eight
seasons of youth soccer brady no
documented soccer experience gutfeldt in
2000 was editor-in-chief of stuff
magazine brady in 2000 was drafted in
the sixth round the 199th pick what a
loser and finally brady is known for not
shaking hands after a loss gup belt
shakes hands with all human beings
regardless of age race sex or political
affiliation this has been the tale of
the tape gutfeld versus brady
yes
cat
can't we agree that i am happier than
tom brady he might be tad better looking
and slightly better in sports but i am
happier you know me as a happy person i
can't get any happier
i would never say that about you
i don't
know yeah have you ever got a happy text
yeah
i just want to make sure you have a
great day
no no no
like you won't believe me yeah
really i'm writing you to inform you
that that behavior will not be tolerated
you've ruined my day yeah you know i
don't
yeah right i knew i should have been an
nfl quarterback
you couldn't pick up a football i could
i used two hands i could yes
but you can't throw a football with two
hands but you know you know tyrus him
and i both went to the same high school
i have to bring that up all the time
and i'm tired of the fact that like they
named a field after him when my name is
got f
spelled
but it's like they they could have they
could call it gut-feld field well maybe
you'll get the library you know because
you write books yeah i don't think so i
did the library at sarah high school was
not clean it was it was a very dirty
discussion how would you know
yeah you know i think he's the reason
why probably yeah you know you make sure
yeah this action might work out in your
favor historically when the greats
go to broadcasting it doesn't play out
very well
jordan muhammad ali a lot of the
all-time greats they played a game at
such a high level when they talk about
it they come across condescending oh
because there's no one better than they
are yeah they and when guy they watch
other guys play they're super critical
so this might not be
a great i hate to say it but this could
possibly be the best thing that ever
happened to you oh fantastic
he's gonna come to you for help yes and
i won't be there for him because where
was he when i needed help ari
where answer me were you secretary who
graduated first you were him uh well i
know we look so close in age but i did
graduate first
just a little 1980 what did 87. early
though too though correct yes that's yes
because i was uh you know i was like
doogie howser
i went to uh i went to med school when i
was 14.
well i'm a miami dolphin fan i love you
all bless your heart i am cheering
cheering for brady to fail yeah i mean
it's just like a sunday for 15 years in
a row where he never did but i'm still
cheering for him to fail ah you know i
hope he does well because i'm
magnanimous dagen
magnanimous i've never said that word
out loud
um
with this contract now i know why the
snacks are looking a little thin
yes
you know where's my chex mix oh yeah i
know they're cutting cutting corners
already that's right
40 million dollars a year that's like
twice what i make so
wait say what
i'm just you know they have to cut
corners somewhat you know that they just
they just they just removed the entire
outnumbered show
they just dissolved it no they just
removed the couch
[Laughter]
now
yes outnumbered sleepover yes
great idea i'll add one thing though tom
brady is probably thinking tv's really
easy and it's super hard cat went
through the
all the necessary grooming even for men
but like if you don't blink you look
like a psychopath and if you blink too
much you look like a psychopath so you
have to find that happy medium and i've
yet to find it in 20 years
well you know what i'm happy
and i'm a medium
at least at the gap very magnanimous of
you thank you
up next dream mega if the extreme
unanimous that's funny up next if the
pilot passes out could you land without
a doubt hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else